Kesha is back with a vengeance as
yourself good to the robbed in China
saga continues
plus I'm hanging with the cast of
spider-man homecoming get it hang in
through the webslinger you're hanging
from buildings I'll see myself out my
friends don't leave because of that joke
there is so much to celebrate today on
the daily Denny it's National fried
chicken day I got a new hair product I
really like and Kesha returns now you
know I love my pop stars on this show
and it's been nearly four years since
Kesha has released a new single after a
nasty legal battle and she's come back
in a huge way the song is praying it's
raw emotional and it's just as sparkly
as you like your Kesha visuals but it's
her vocals on this one that got me shook
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ah come through Ke$ha we are so happy
you are back and clearly she had a
message to send because she seemingly
references her former producer dr. Luke
in the song whom she was in 8 years long
legal battle with after accusing him of
sexual and emotional abuse but listen
carefully because the song not only
hints at forgiveness but Kesha herself
pendant essay for lena Dunham's Eleni
letter and says the single is about
quote coming to feel empathy for someone
else even if they hurt you or scare you
it's a song about learning to be proud
of the person you are even during low
moments when you feel alone it's also
about hoping everyone even someone who
hurt you can heal and to that I say a
men and good news animals because
there's more to come for first album
since 2012 warrior is titled rainbow and
drops August 11th now while Ke$ha is
busy pouring out her soul we're still
waiting for Rob Kardashian made good on
his plans for his own lemonade album
after he went off on social media
yesterday calling out blac chyna for
cheating on him yes the saga continues
today I'm afraid
just yesterday Rob went off on Instagram
and Twitter posting naked pics allegedly
of China claiming she was on drugs and
cheated on him with multiple men he also
claimed he spent hundreds of thousands
of dollars on jewelry for her and today
the man believed to be kissing up on
China in a video Rob alleges she trusted
him is speaking out the guy who goes by
Ferrari true 3 on Instagram posted a new
pic in bed with China and another of her
draped in jewelry that is seemingly for
Rob because he captioned the photo that
250k in jewelry ain't means blank to
Rory 100 rep yo says now admittedly I
have no clue what that means so if any
of you do please let me know but who
else could that be aimed at meanwhile
blac Chyna's lawyer tells ET she is
taking the matter seriously and is
exploring legal remedies against Rob so
we'll see how this all plays out folks
but let's turn around the crazy because
not only is it national fried chicken
day apparently it's also international
kissing day and while there's a day for
everything but I couldn't resist
sharing this throwback for Miley Cyrus
Miley is celebrating the day with this
shot with boyfriend Liam Hemsworth on
the set of their movie the last song
where it all began she captioned the pic
our first smooch eight years ago and of
course et was with the two while
promoting the film back in 2010 and just
take a listen at what Miley had to say
about falling for Liam on set if there's
chemistry with so much chemistry with
someone and I'm not going to lie to that
about that once you know people see us
on screen together and now speaking of
chemistry wait until you see the young
TAS of spider-man homecoming together on
screen the studio is banking on this new
cast to put a fresh spin on the
franchise and take it from me they are
obsessed with each other in real life I
found out firsthand when I caught up
with them including our new Spidey Tom
Holland gets a call you're going to be
in a Marvel movie during the inspire man
what was your reaction I went absolutely
nuts jumped out of they were screaming
and shouting ha ha ha I hope the phone
and then I proceeded to scream and cry
and jump all in one market guys are
losers so I was extremely excited I was
like it's a whole new cast and for good
reason
Peter Parker and friends have always
been high school Tobey Maguire the
original is 42 now he was followed by
Andrew Garfield now 33 so enters a much
closer to high school Tom Holland who's
21 listen I know school sucks Peter all
movie takes place on such a different
backdrop yeah having a character exists
whether other superheroes that's right
Spidey is now part of the Avengers
universe and we're seeing a completely
different version of spider Peter Parker
is an intern for Robert Downey's Tony
Stark I can keep that suit yeah son to
me that's like not a reboot yeah
basically Aunt May is back played this
time by Oscar winner Marisa Tomei
she's very maternal she's always worried
about him Aunt May is definitely getting
younger
the original rosemary Harris played her
at age 74 next king Sally Field at 65
Marisa is only 52 it was really actually
an interesting challenge because
generally in our culture it's like you
can't be maternal and sexual at the same
time one thing will never change
Spidy stuff will always be death-defying
I would go as far as they wanted me to
go until they would stop I cannot say
enough good things about this movie but
I'm not the only one
please welcome back to the daily Jenny a
resident movie Queen and all things
marvel ash crossing I'm so glad you
finally sell this movie so we can geek
out together I did see it and I'm
telling you I have not been able to stop
smiling while talking about it it's some
of the most brilliant subtle most
cleverly written jokes I've ever seen in
a superhero movie it's so good you guys
and lucky for you out there I was about
to take you on a deep dive of homecoming
oh yes I get into the specifics of what
you need to know first and breaking down
that whole semi confusing Marvel Sony
deal on behind the screens right here on
our YouTube page and on Saturday I'll be
talking spoilers and moving come back
cannot wait I swear this is the Beyonce
of superhero movies yeah - thank you so
much girl all right you guys be sure to
subscribe to e t--'s youtube channel to
catch behind the screen and of course
the daily Denny now there's plenty more
of my hang with the spider-man Home
Coming cast including Michael Keene who
is playing vulture 25 years after Batman
Returns that's all over at each
online.com so go watch it all right I'm
gonna shimmy out of here you guys